this used to be the only yardstick for
how well a company was doing
but today it's no longer enough for
businesses just to do well they are also
expected to do good
more and more companies are getting more
focused on social responsibility
investors are increasingly concerned
about the impact on the climate
people are feeling more confident about
calling companies out for their lack of
diversity
helping to facilitate this shift is new
technology
from greenhouse gas sensors
to supply chain trackers
but what does this more cuddly form of
capitalism mean for the bottom line
[Music]
this would have once been unthinkable
this is the plane we're gonna be using
today so this is a twin engine navajo
and uh our camera is installed inside
the cabin
an aerial survey commissioned by a
fossil fuels company in order to reduce
its carbon footprint
we're gonna go do a flight uh doing some
methane monitoring so we're gonna be
flying over some oil and gas sites and
we'll be monitoring for for emissions
and leaks from those facilities
it reflects a growing awareness of
climate change within the corporate
world
including the biggest polluters
we need energy operators who can produce
the energy we need in a responsible way
we want to enable them to have the
information that they need to make that
appropriate
decision
[Music]
using a special sensor ghg sat can
identify methane leaks so the fossil
fuel companies can plug them
as the sunlight hits the ground and the
light comes up through the atmosphere if
there's methane there our sensor will
see an absorption of that sunlight
signal
it's thought that methane causes about a
quarter of man-made global warming in
the short term it's a much more potent
greenhouse gas than carbon dioxide
we need to address both let's be clear
about that
but if you want a faster return on your
investment
really it's a great idea to target
methane first
the incentive for the fossil fuel
companies is to save money by losing
less methane but there are longer-term
financial incentives too
when we first started ghg saturn almost
10 years ago everybody assumed we were
doing this for regulatory reasons that
operators would be motivated by the fact
that regulators will insist that they do
this that's not the driving factor today
it's because their customers want them
to do it it's because their investors
want them to do it it's because their
own employees
want them to do it there's a whole
generation coming into the workforce now
that absolutely insists that their
companies respect the environment and
show that they're serious about tackling
climate change
the other thing that we should just go
over is how to load up a different block
so once you finish one line it'll be
having to open up the next one
as well as collecting data by plane
ghgsat also uses satellites to pinpoint
emissions we can see emissions from
individual facilities anywhere in the
world we take that data and we convert
it into useful information that
companies and governments and analysts
can use to better understand the
emissions and ultimately control them
and reduce them
they've also created a publicly
available emissions map it's access to
data like this that is helping to inform
a generation of more conscious customers
who balance their desire to shop with a
wish for a cleaner planet
recent research found that 81 of
consumers feel strongly that companies
should help improve the environment with
younger age groups the most likely to
believe it's important
mary kay bush has seen firsthand the
rise of this more demanding demographic
over more than four decades working in
business and finance she served three
american presidents and sat on numerous
corporate boards
if a company is harming the environment
in which they operate they are
potentially harming the health of their
own employees of people in the community
people who could be their customers can
you do that over a long period of time
and continue to have those people as
customers have a brand that is hopefully
liked by those customers
companies are remarkably wasteful
it's good for their bottom line if they
operate more efficiently but even
companies that are not directly seen as
big emitters the tech companies in
silicon valley for them too there's very
much a marketing benefit that comes from
embracing climate-friendly factors as
well
ultimately the most important thing is
that the planet needs them to do it
[Music]
it's part of a growing trend in business
to talk of values beyond merely making
money
a marked shift from the 70s and 80s when
the shareholder was king
profits were the priority and greed was
good
but the world became more globalized and
the pressure on companies to be more
socially responsible grew
then came the financial crisis in 2008
and faith in governments declined
[Music]
instead the public began to turn to
companies to fix society's most pressing
problems
a recent global survey found that more
than two-thirds of people believed ceos
should step in when governments fail to
fix societal problems
businesses primary responsibilities to
their shareholders they own the company
but there is a lot of pressure
being placed on big companies that wield
so much power in the community and the
country in the world people have almost
begun to look at them like quasi
governments
balancing the demands of society with
those of shareholders requires
innovation
so what does this mean for the bottom
line
[Music]
take an issue highlighted by the covert
19 pandemic how companies treat their
employees
at the height of the pandemic factories
such as this polymer manufacturer in
karachi were faced with a simple choice
keep their employees safe
or shut down
covert was a new phenomena to make
people come out of their homes and work
at a plant site where there are multiple
people they were confused whether they
will be affected or not and what kind of
majors we are taking as employees
fearing a loss in production the factory
turned to technology to create a safe
working environment
using ai to track whether employees are
complying with covert rules
the tech is designed by british company
empiricai
using cctv feeds it calculates whether
workers are socially distancing and
wearing face masks correctly
this red line is showing the violation
of social distancing is at this location
all the areas are being covered vast
number of observations are higher in the
ion technicians office
so we will report it to the building
owner and see what majors we can take to
reduce these
had we not had this software
we would not have operated our plant
with so much comfort and with
sustainable runs
when we showed people analytics
reassured them that they are complying
with the requirements and there is no
exposure to them from their co-workers
the pandemic brought out the importance
of employee welfare from day one
from a health point of view immediately
it was absolutely vital for companies to
look after their employees not just for
the employees benefit per se but the
reputational risks of having an
explosion of covert in your factory was
huge
but the use of this tech is not always
benevolent some companies have been
overzealous in tracking the movements
and behaviour of remote workers and
employees
sometimes these days it's almost as if
companies know more about their
employees than the employees families do
not just when they clock in and when
they clock out but when they go to the
bathroom it can be very dispiriting for
employees certainly there are concerns
about privacy aspects of this too
[Music]
a recent survey of british employees
found that almost three-quarters of
those surveyed felt that workplace
surveillance would damage trust
and unhappy workers are bad for business
it's really important to have happy
workers in order to have workers who are
prepared to chip in their thoughts and
their ideas and and that's really what
business is all about
the productivity of a company can also
be affected by the diversity of its
workforce
the black lives matter protests in 2020
pushed racial injustice and lack of
diversity in workplaces up the corporate
agenda
i've been mistaken for a defendant on
numerous occasions black people are
hugely over-represented in the criminal
justice system
alexandra wilson is a british criminal
and family law barrister who has
first-hand experience of these problems
i think even now i can count on one hand
probably without my thumb the amount of
times i've seen a black judge
but yet i could you know i could count
numerous black defenders day in and day
out
alongside her day job alexandra
campaigns for greater diversity in the
workplace and argues more diversity
means better business
i think that if you've got a diverse
pool of talent and that doesn't have to
be racial diversity only you know that
that's gender diversity that's looking
at sexual orientation your company can
think about things in more innovative
ways
that goes for every sector from the
legal sector that i'm in to the creative
sectors
alexandra's career was kick-started with
the help of diversity recruitment
company rare
its founder rafael mercades believes
there are huge benefits to be gained
from hiring employees like alexandra
from socially diverse and deprived
backgrounds the issue has always been is
it a correlation or is it a causality
i.e does a diversity drive the
performance or perhaps is it that higher
performing organizations can afford to
spend money on diversity i think you can
say reasonably is becoming apparent that
individual high performers are
disproportionately likely to be people
from lower achieving schools who've got
very good grades
those gritty resilient out performers
tend to continue to outperform
rare has designed an algorithm that
helps companies to identify candidates
with high potential from
underrepresented backgrounds
it creates a level playing field by
comparing candidates exam results at 18
against the average of other students at
their school
a student with three a's might seem more
impressive than a student from another
school with an a and two b's
but if the average result at the first
student school was three a's and the
second was three ds
then the second student becomes a more
impressive choice
[Music]
the algorithm combines this with other
information such as whether they
received free school meals or whether
they were a refugee and generates a
number which can be used by employers to
better compare candidates
i want to look at people from schools in
the bottom 40
i want them to have outperformed their
average by at least 40 there's one here
at leicester one at brunell these are
very much the sorts of people that you
might
miss
in a traditional campus recruitment
round so if we look at this candidate
from city for example
looks remarkable you're talking about
four
contextual flags an outperformance of 40
which looks great and she'll make some
of them
hopefully
a lot of money
that level playing field is hugely
important
i grew up in birmingham alabama
in the 50s and 60s blacks in high-level
corporate jobs was basically unheard of
when you think about extra energy that
you've got to exert when you can't just
walk through the door but you got to pry
open the door
then that's productive energy that could
be used for some company and creating
new products or expanding to new markets
research by mckinsey found that the most
ethnically diverse management teams were
a third more likely to outperform the
least diverse teams when it comes to
profits
ultimately there is going to come a time
if that time hasn't come already where
clients are going to look to companies
and expect that those companies are
representative
people are feeling more confident about
calling companies out for their lack of
diversity i look at companies and i
think if i can't see representation
there i'd rather put my money where i
can see representation
sixty percent of american consumers said
a brand's reaction to the black lives
matter protests would influence whether
they'd buy from or boycott them in the
future
some companies have incorporated
diversity into their marketing
in 2016 colin kaepernick an nfl
quarterback took the knee during the u.s
national anthem
out of that protest by colin kaepernick
you can see kaepernick kneeling on the
sideline his action inspired hundreds of
other sports stars to do the same
two years later nike made kaepernick the
face of its advertising campaign
[Music]
so don't ask if your dreams are crazy
ask if they're crazy enough
they took a calculated decision that
this was a principled stance for one
thing but also a stance that was going
to appeal to their consumers as well the
difficulty that companies face is that
if they take a political decision they
may well alienate
some of their consumers
politics
that's always a tough subject
people
in this country certainly are free to
exercise their vote and exercise their
voice but is it proper to do that within
the company there are some issues that
are sometimes so egregious that people
have to speak up but people also have to
learn puts the line too far and i think
we are feeling our way and people are
learning
[Music]
for companies this delicate balance
between doing good and doing what's best
for the bottom line is also apparent in
the growing scrutiny of supply chains in
particular products that come from china
companies are on the horns of a very
tricky dilemma at the moment on the one
hand they are under pressure to be much
more picky about the goods that they use
and how they are produced on the other
hand they
sell into china and produce in china and
if they could they would have nothing to
do with internal politics in china
because they know what a dangerous game
it is
in 2020 companies that use cotton grown
in the xinjiang region of china came
under the spotlight hundreds of
thousands of people from ethnic
minorities are being forced to pick
cotton
home to the uyga community there was
concern that forced labour had been used
in the production of the cotton
firms rushed to reassure their western
customers that they didn't source cotton
from xinjiang
but in retaliation china threatened to
ban the brands
this is what happens when your brand
ignites the wrath of the world's biggest
fashion market
[Music]
the tricky thing is that cotton is very
hard to trace
but one company may have a way to ensure
that ethical standards are being
maintained in supply chains
applied dna sciences has developed a way
of tagging cotton fibres with dna
molecules
for cotton which doesn't normally have
its own identity we use dna tagging to
establish identity when we create a
unique molecular tag that tag designates
the date the time the place the location
even the social and ethical practices
that are adopted at that particular
location for that precise type of cotton
the tagging usually happens once the
cotton has been picked it's sent to a
cotton gin to be cleaned and then
sprayed with a fine mist of the dna
molecular tag that tag can't be tampered
with and certainly it cannot be copied
by tagging it we can ensure that that
cotton stays that way from the fiber to
the yarn to the fabric all the way to
the finished product
so show me the sample
that corresponds to the cotton that we
tagged
being able to trace the cotton in their
products helps companies avoid costly
lawsuits as well as ensure they are
getting the quality of cotton that they
paid for and it can be used as a
marketing tool
so the pima we grow is the pima you get
the brands and manufacturers we're
working with have decided that this is a
great way to be able to show the
consumer they are being proactive
integrity of supply chain is directly
related to trust and when companies make
claims that are not true
that they're really one click away
from damaging their whole brand
[Music]
from ethical supply chains to diversity
employee welfare to the environment the
pressures on companies to be more
socially responsible are increasingly
influencing where investors put their
money
but how do you work out which companies
are actually doing good
enter esg esg esg esg environmental
social and governance
esg is in a sense a way of
measuring for companies things apart
from the bottom line it looks at their
impact on the environment it looks at
their impact in terms of the people that
they hire the impact in terms of the way
the company is run in a sense it creates
a more holistic view of the company than
just the dollars and cents that it spits
out at the end of every quarter
for businesses scoring highly on esg
metrics is becoming increasingly crucial
in the past decade there's been a nearly
four-fold increase of sustainable funds
available to american investors
but there aren't standardized criteria
for measuring esg compliance so it can
be hard to choose
[Music]
rep risk a zurich based analytics
company has one solution for the new
breed of ethical
investor we're essentially looking at
what the world is saying about a company
rather than what the company itself is
reporting about its activities instead
of just looking at what they're
disclosing which sometimes may be in
transparent or biased or may mask risks
we're looking at a way that serves as a
reality check we tell our clients how in
fact is this company managing human
rights managing climate change or any
other esg issue around the world where
they operate so if you look at this now
oh wow okay so we're really talking rep
risk has developed ai to scour over a
hundred thousand different sources from
around the world from news reports think
tanks and even social media
if a risk is identified a human analyst
takes over looking at its severity how
new it is and where the source comes
from
a lot of these factories that have been
sampled by the ngo they supply garments
to a lot of well-known fashion brands
the data from rep risk is used by banks
insurance companies and asset managers
to work out where to invest their money
i think today it's well accepted that
esg has gone mainstream
that it's no longer a nice to have but a
must-have
the way that a company manages esg
issues can be seen as how future-proof
they are in an ever-changing world
the question is whether a company that
focuses a lot on its social
responsibility does actually produce
better returns over the long term
the chances are that we will see a
correlation emerging there it's been
somewhat obscured lately by the fact
that some of the companies that perform
best on esg scores like the tech
companies have had the most fantastic
stock market run-ups
while we live in a world in which there
is not a lot of trust in governments
there's pressure on anyone in society to
deliver better social outcomes right now
ceos are really in the frame there
there is a risk to this if a ceo's
mission reflects what the wider public
wants but not what the shareholders want
they could find themselves in hot water
the ceo of danon a french company was a
strong supporter of sustainability but
in 2021 he was ousted by shareholders
because of danon's languishing share
price
the danger inherent in all of this is
that ceos can easily fall into
grandstanding this burnishes their
status in society if they stand up and
sound like they're acting as saviors of
the world and that can cause quite a
dissonance that shareholders get very
uncomfortable with
but as the average age of shareholders
falls their priorities might change too
the average age of a first-time investor
has fallen from 45 in 2012
to 37 in 2021
which means the pressures on businesses
to do good are unlikely to go away
companies really take a big risk in not
listening to what that demographic is
thinking and saying and doing
i think we're on a path that businesses
are going to see they have to get
innovative in order to be responsive to
that and still serve their shareholders
give them that new product play more
style better quality new features and at
the right price i don't think this is a
short-term thing
[Music]
i'm henry tricks business columnist at
the economist to keep up to date on esg
and the changing demands on business
please click on the link opposite
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
and thanks very much for watching
you